CHRISTINE DRAZEN IS TRAILING
DEMOCRAT TINA KOTEK BY JUST FOUR
POINTS.
CHRISTINE DRAZEN JOINS ME NOW.
I CAME ACROSS THIS STATISTIC AND
IT SHOCKED ME AND I THOUGHT I
HAD SEEN IT ALL BUT LAST YEAR
MEXICO CITY HAD A LOWER HOMICIDE
RATE PER CAPITA THAN PORTLAND
OREGON?
SO HOW DO VOTERS KEEP VALIDATING
THAT TYPE OF LEADERSHIP IN THIS
CLIMATE?
>> WELL, HERE'S THE THING.
IT'S NOT UNCOMFORTABLY CLOSE FOR
OREGONIANS.
OREGONIANS ARE REACHING CHANGE
BECAUSE IT'S NOT GOOD ENOUGH.
THERE IS NO UNIVERSE WHERE THE
MURDER RATE IN PORTLAND SHOULD
BE CLOSE TO THE MURDER RATE IN
MEXICO CITY.
AND OREGONIANS ARE DONE, THEY'RE
DONE WITH IT, THEY'RE DONE WITH
THE EXCUSES AND POOR LEADERSHIP
AND SINGLE PARTY CONTROL.
THERE IS NO AMOUNT OF SPIN THAT
CAN COVER UP WHAT IT'S LIKE
RIGHT NOW IN OUR URBAN CENTERS
AND ACROSS OUR STATE.
OREGONIANS DESERVE BETTER AND
ARE DEMANDING BETTER.
>> Laura: EVERY TIME I LOOK AT
SORT OF THE NEWS, YOU KNOW,
CYCLE FOR OREGON NOW, IT HAS
SOMETHING TO DO WITH SOME
HORRIFIC CRIMES THAT ARE TAKING
PLACE.
>> YEAH.
>> Laura: LIKE THIS MORNING IT
WAS A GUY WIELDING SOME TYPE OF
WEAPON, I GUESS HE HAD A RIFLE
TRYING TO SET FIRE TO MERCEDES.
THE POLICE HAD TO SHOOT AT HIM
TO TRY TO STOP THIS BECAUSE THEY
WERE WORRIED ABOUT EXPLOSIONS.
THIS IS AT 8:52 IN THE MORNING.
>> YEAH.
>> Laura: AND YET YOU'VE LIST
BETH WARREN OUT THERE MAKING A
PITCH TO VOTERS FOR YOUR
OPPONENT.
WATCH THIS.
>> EVERYTHING IS ON THE LINE,
OUR REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS, OUR
HEALTHCARE, THE NEEDS OF WORKING
FAMILIES AND OUR DEMOCRACY
ITSELF.
AND THAT IS WHY IT IS SO
IMPORTANT TO ELECT TINA KOTEK.
PLEASE, GET THAT BALLOT IN, AND
VOTE FOR TINA KOTEK FOR OREGON
GOVERNOR.
LET'S PET THIS DONE.
>> Laura: ABORTION AND
DEMOCRACY.
NO WONDER EASTERN OREGON WANTS
TO SUS SEED TO IDAHO WITH THAT
PITCH.
>> IT'S TONE DEAF.
IT IS TONE DEAF.
YOU HAVE TO BE COMPLETELY
OBLIVIOUS TO WHAT LIFE IS LIKE
IN OREGON TO COME HERE AND MAKE
A NATIONAL DC ELITE PITCH TO
OREGON VOTERS RIGHT NOW IS
COMPLETELY TONE DEAF.
OREGONIANS ACROSS THE STATE ARE
TALKING ABOUT KITCHEN TABLE
ISSUES, THE THINGS THAT ACTUALLY
AFFECT REAL PEOPLE.
INFLATION, RISING COSTS, RISING
CRIME, LOWER QUALITY OF LIFE
ACROSS OUR STATE AND CERTAINLY
EDUCATION STANDARDS THAT HAVE
PLUMMETED UNDER DEMOCRAT
LEADERSHIP.
MY OPPONENT TINA KOTEK HAS BEEN
IN CHARGE.
SHE HAS LINKED ARMS WITH
GOVERNOR KATE BROWN IN THESE
LAST SIX YEARS AND HAS DRIVEN
OUR BEAUTIFUL STATE, OUR GREAT
STATE OF OREGON INTO THE DITCH
AND OREGONIANS THEMSELVES RESIST
DESERVING BETTER.
THE FACT THAT GOOD MORNING
AMERICA WOULD VIEW IT AS
DANGEROUSLY CLOSE.
>> Laura: UNCOMFORTABLY CLOSE.
>> OUR CHANCE TO TURN IT AROUND
IS TOMORROW.
>> Laura: UNCOMFORTABLY CLOSE.
YES OR NO THAT BALLOT MEASURE
PUSHING FOR STRICTER GUN CONTROL
PASS?
YES OR NO?
>> I SAY NO.
>> Laura: THAT'S THE ONLY ONE OF
ITS KIND IN THE COUNTRY AND A
VERY ODD RESPONSE TO THE CRIME
RATE GOING UP IN YOUR STATE.
CHRISTINE WE ARE VERY PROUD OF
THIS CAMPAIGN YOU RAN AND WE'R